así es todo está listo ya para que esta
tarde a las 16 30 arranquen estos
diálogos entre la oposición y el
gobierno de venezuela sabemos que ya
están definidos los representantes del
lado de la oposición estará tomás
guanipa quien fuera representante de
waldo en colombia él estará por el
partido primero justicia henrique
capriles quien incluso no se descarta
también esté presente por acá estará
stalin gonzález el ex vicepresidente de
la asamblea y gerardo blyde el ex
legislador y ex alcalde de baruta por
parte del gobierno de maduro estará
jorge rodríguez el líder de la asamblea
héctor rodríguez quien es el gobernador
del estado de miranda y también estará
el hijo de nicolás maduro nicolás
ernesto maduro guerra hay mucha
expectativa el gobierno incluso de
estados unidos a través del portavoz del
departamento de estado en el price pues
confío en que se avance que haya
verdaderos avances en esas negociaciones
y en esa medida dijo nicolás madura
puede crear un camino hacia el
levantamiento de sanciones económicas
estaremos muy pendientes de lo que
ocurra todo está puesto para que den
inicio estas pláticas así es mariah
vamos a ver entonces lo que ocurre muy
pendientes con usted allá en ciudad de
méxico